okay so Gavilan here is smack bang in
the middle of the fourth series it's
perhaps most famous for the fact that
it's used as a contrast reagent in MRI
machines so if you need a full-body scan
doctor will come along and inject you
with a solution which contains a bit of
gadolinium and what it basically does is
it changes the way that molecules water
molecules react in your body when
they're scanned and then you can see the
contrast between healthy tissue and
perhaps unhealthy tissue and then that
aids the doctors in their assignment
what the thing about the lanthanide
series is that it's probably the best
example of a smooth contraction of size
as you move from the left hand side to
the right hand side and that you lose
about 25% of the radius of the atoms as
you move from left to right and this is
called the lanthanide contraction and
this is actually what's responsible for
second and third row transition metals
having very similar types of chemistry
by group even though actually there
should be quite different there the
third row third row should be much
larger but because of the lanthanide
contraction that increase in sizes
counterbalance so they actually end up
being more or less the same size as
their second row counter parts even
chemists sometimes wonder how people can
get excited about particular parts of
chemistry and the rare earth elements
are elements which those who are not
working in the area don't see always see
white can be very exciting so when I was
a student I saw an advertisement in the
lab where I was working about a lecture
about the oxidation states of the rare
earths elements and the relatively
relative stability of two of the
oxidation states by chemists called
David Johnson who in those days worked
for the Open University and I went to
this lecture because I couldn't imagine
how anybody could make it interesting
and it was really fascinating he was so
enthused
to concern by the end I rushed out
really quite excited if I went and
bought this book which has been sitting
on my bookshelf ever since and has been
quite useful for teaching some my
students